افاد مراسل الجزيره باستشهاد مسن وشاب
برصاص قناصه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في محيط
مستشفى ناصر بخان يونس جنوبي قطاع غزه
صباح اليوم واضاف مراسلنا ان قوات
الاحتلال اجبرت النازحين على مغادره
مدرستي شيخ جبر وقنديل في مخيم خان
يونس تما فيك الله يع في السيارات هنا
والله عند اجل
السيارات لاك يا حاج على البوابه هديك
بالشبه الحق الحق بسرعه بسرعه بسرعه يا
عطوى هي جاي جاي معنا من رفح مراسلنا هشام
زقوت هشام كيف كانت الليله الماضيه في رفح
وفي عموم جنوب القطاع لا سما في خان يونس
ووضع هؤلاء النازحين الذين يجبرهم
الاحتلال على مغادره المدارس التي كانت
تؤويهم بالفعل مريم ليلى صعبه للغايه على
كافه مناطق جنوب قطاع غزه وحتى على
المناطق الوسطى ومدينه غزه القصف
الاسرائيلي لم يتوقف ولا دقيقه واحده قصف
من الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه قصف من
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه كذلك الزوارق
الحربيه شاركت في عمليه القصف خاصه في
المناطق الغربيه لخاني وس وهي ايضا مناطق
يتحدث الجيش الاسرائيلي انها امنه وهي
منطقه المواصي الجيش الاسرائيلي كثف
الليله الماضيه من قصف تلك المناطق وشواطئ
مدينه خانيونس الغربيه بالاضافه الى اعاده
الى اعاده تموضع وتمركز قواته في محيط
جامعه الاقصى في المناطق الغربيه لخان
يونس الان التمركز والتموضع للجيش
الاسرائيلي ولاليات العسكريه والدبابات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه في محيط مدارس تابعه
لوكاله غوث وتشغيل اللاجئين الاونر وهي
يتواجد فيها مئات من النازحين الفلسطينيين
مدارس العوده واكثر من مدرسه بجانبها وهي
مقابله لمستشفى ناصر في مدينه خانيونس
وهذا المستشفى ما زال يتعرض محيطه الى قصف
من المدفعيه الاسرائيليه قصف من الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه وجلها تستهدف المنازل
المدنيه المحيطه لمستشفى ناصر كذلك طائرات
كواد كابتر اسرائيليه تطلق النار على
المواطنين الفلسطينين والنازحين الذين
يحاولون اما التزود بالمياه من مستشفى
ناصر لانه يتواجد فيه بعض كهرباء وبالتالي
يمكن الحصول على بعض المياه الصالحه للشرب
لكن الطائرات الاسرائيليه كواد كابتر
المسيره تطلق النار على هؤلاء الذين
يحاولون قطع الشارع وايضا هناك قناصه
اسرائيليون يطلقون النار على كل من يحاول
التحرك في محيط هذه المدارس وبالتالي كان
هناك عدد من الشهداء اخرهم شهيد مسن
وشهيده حاولوا قطع الشارع فعالج الناصع
الاسرائيليين بالرصاص واستشهدوا من جراء
اطلاق النار عليهم كذلك هناك عمليات قصف
اسرائيلي مستمره في حي الامل وهي وهذا
الحي ايضا يتعرض منذ بدايه العمليه البريه
لمدينه خانيونس للقصف الاسرائيلي ونحن
نتحدث عن مركز حي الامل ومستشفى حي الامل
التابع للهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني هشام زقوت
من رفح شكرا لك